one of the things that's quite
interesting about people who have
Rousseau lien ideas about children so
children are all good and they get
corrupted by society which is half true
because they're also not good and they
get shaped in and disciplined by society
but the resilient types off there are
very interesting when their kids hit
teenage years or when they're judging
likes a criminal teenagers it's like the
child is perfect until they hit like 11
then they turn into a teenager and then
they're like thugs so they go from good
to thug in one move you know and and you
often see that families - that have
treated especially their daughters like
a princess you know and then they hit
puberty and and parents who have
princess them to death have no idea what
to do with them and so then they become
demonized and so that the overly good
the child turns into the overly wicked
teenager and sometimes they'll act that
out - one of the things I've seen with
girls who are held in princess esteem
when they're little and their parents
have to tight a grip on them and too
much of a demand for good behaviors
they'll find some nasty character to
associate with who will tear them out of
the family you know bikers are really
good for that sort of thing so and
especially if you have some vengeful
thoughts towards your parents
nice biker is your perfect solution to
that problem